nous reprenons cette lettre, la lettre de Polo Galate,
qui reçoit le surnom de la lettre de la liberté,
la lettre de l'affranchissement.
Et c'est un rappel recourant pour nous.
Regardez la forêt avant de considérer la feuille.
C'est toujours important, car dans la compréhension biblique
de ce qui est la vraie liberté,
c'est de retrouver cet état de béatitude
telle qu'elle est désignée pour Dieu.
Si nous sommes tous dans l'expérience
de ces manques de paix,
nous avons tous aussi cette aspiration pour la paix.
Donc quand on constate par exemple les fruits de l'esprit
qui sont les évidences de la restauration
de ce qui nous devrions être,
c'est pourquoi Dieu nous a créés,
nous retrouverons les fruits de l'esprit
présentés dans un passage qui parle plus explicitement
de cette conception de liberté chrétienne.
Donc c'est ces caractères symétriques,
équilibrés,
qui réjouissent à la une,
de manière radicale,
de cet amour,
de cette joie,
de cette paix.
Et nous sommes donc devant cette conception
que si on pourrait imaginer
ou expérimenter
la liberté parfaite,
elle ne passe pas qu'il par
les expressions externes
externes dans nos comportements,
mais ça commence radicalement
au-dedans de nous,
dans notre esprit.
Donc bien sûr que cet amour expérimenté
de la part des dieux dans l'évangile
doit s'afficher à l'extérieur
envers mes semblables.
Mais nous savons que nous pouvons
donner l'impression
à l'extérieur
de vivre apparemment la liberté,
de nous comporter extérieurement
envers les autres
comme si nous étions des personnes
qui les aiment.
Mais nous savons que parfois
il nous manque la sensation
fondamentale et radicale
d'être aimé
et un vrai sentiment
envers l'autrui
d'amour.
C'est la même chose
par rapport à la paix.
Nous pouvons donner
l'impression externe
que nous sommes des personnes
pacifiques,
paisibles,
que nous avons de la paix,
mais nous connaissons très bien
toutes les crises
et troubles
que nous faisons face
dans cette bataille intérieure.
Les personnes n'ont pas toujours
accès aux crises d'anxiété
qu'on peut être
en train de traverser.
Les personnes
ne peuvent pas toujours
percevoir
que mon attitude
d'esprit à l'intérieur
n'est pas une attitude
d'épais envers cette personne.
Mon comportement
peut sembler
paisible,
pacifique,
tolérant
et la conception
biblique
d'épais
n'est pas tout simplement
dirigée à l'extérieur.
Donc,
quand on considère
la conception biblique
des libertés,
c'est une liberté
qui s'exprime
à l'extérieur
de toutes les passions
charnelles
qui un jour
nous ont contrôlées,
mais
pour que nous
puissions vivre
dans la promotion
de ces qualités
que nous sommes
en train de considérer
qui, bien sûr,
se manifesteront
de manière extérieure
mais qui ne peuvent
pas exister
de manière
réelle
et biblique
dans leur conception
la plus élevée
si ce n'est pas
une réalité
expérimentée
à l'intérieur.
C'est une liberté
d'esprit.
en Christ.
C'est cette union
avec Jésus Christ.
C'est cette paix
qui sait qu'est
le Seigneur Jésus
qui peut proporcioner.
C'est cette paix
qui sait le Seigneur Jésus
le seul capable
en lui-même
d'expérimenter parfaitement
et que nous ne pouvons
qu'à l'expérimenter
en lui
comme nous allons voir.
Et donc,
la liberté,
c'est cette symétrie
des caractères
qui représentent
les caractères
du Christ lui-même
qui nous avions perdu
dans notre rébellion
contre Dieu
et qui nous retrouvons
en Jésus.
Donc,
c'est très important
de nous rappeler
la liaison
dans les contextes
entre la conception
des libertés chrétiennes
et les fruits
de l'esprit.
Car le raisonnement
de l'apôtre Paul,
il est très linéaire.
Il va,
et même,
je dirais,
circulaire
dans une même direction,
dans le sens
où il peut
reprendre
quelques concepts
et les enrichir
et continuer
de progresser.
Mais en tout cas,
c'est important
pour nous
de nous rappeler
de cette réalité.
Donc,
la pertinence
de parler
de paix
à l'humanité
est perpétuelle
depuis la chute.
on n'a même pas besoin
de dire
aujourd'hui,
c'est très important
de parler de la paix.
Quand on regarde
les pages de l'histoire,
nous retrouvons toujours
l'humanité en guerre.
dès la chute,
cette division,
cette scision
entre la femme
et l'homme,
leurs premiers enfants,
Caen,
Abel.
Et même si,
en quelques décennies
en arrière,
on a vécu
peut-être
les pages
les plus tragiques
de l'histoire
avec les guerres mondiales,
et on avait tous
cet espoir
vent et vide
que ça serait peut-être
la dernière fois
qu'on verrait
un comportement
si bestial
de l'humanité.
Sauf qu'aujourd'hui,
on a encore des guerres
qui sont en train
d'avoir lieu
à plusieurs endroits.
Et une guerre
aussi très subtile
quand on pense
à l'assassinat
des bébés,
des avortements
qui surmontent déjà
la quantité
de tueries
ou d'assassinats
de presque
toutes les guerres
ensemble.
Et donc,
l'être humain
manifeste
de manière externe
par les guerres
que nous sommes
une race
qui n'expérimente
par la paix.
Le problème,
c'est que les guerres
entre les nations
ne s'est pas
ce qui est
entre les nations.
Les leaders
des nations
capables
de faire la guerre
sont des représentants
des individus
qui sont capables
de faire la guerre.
et même ceux
qui veulent adopter
ou déclarer
la politique
pacifiste
dans nos jours
et on se demande
avec quelle attitude
d'esprit
ils veulent défendre
la tolérance,
les droits
des minorités,
toute la créativité
du cœur corrompu
pour vouloir être
ceux qui veulent être.
et ceux qui nous identifient
de manière très claire
c'est de la colère,
manque de paix,
défendre
un agenda politique
qui réclame
être tolérant
par la purée
actuelle,
comme on a vu
dans les dernières semaines.
Et même si
dans la société
on peut donner
l'impression
que nous vivons en paix
ou que nous cherchons
la paix,
il faut aussi vérifier
comment nous procédons
chez nous,
dans la vie privée,
dans nos relations
avec notre famille.
Et même à l'Église,
là où nous réclamons
les princes de la paix,
comme notre Seigneur,
on se demande parfois
avec quelle attitude
d'esprit
l'Évangile
est prêché.
Avec quelle relation
d'intimité
et d'unité
réelle
une communauté
expérimente
la paix du Christ.
Et c'était notamment
les problèmes
possiblement
les plus
explicites
à l'extérieur
dans l'Église
des Galates.
Pourquoi
vous vous mordez
et vous dévorez
les uns les autres ?
Et remarquez bien,
l'apôtre Paul,
pour traiter
ces problèmes
pratiques
à l'extérieur,
dispute
au sein de l'Église,
à cause
de la théologie,
dispute
à cause
d'une pression
dirigée
vers
une relation
néerotique
envers Dieu,
qui faisait
confiance
ou qui
croyait
sous l'influence
des judaïsants,
que Christ
n'était pas
suffisant
pour promouvoir
la paix totale,
la réconciliation
totale avec Dieu,
mais qu'il nous
fallait encore
faire confiance
à notre
performance
religieuse
et d'adopter
à nouveau
certaines pratiques
de la période
cérémonielle
juive.
Garder
certaines dates,
je vais revenir
vite faire
quelques exemples
recourants,
si on ne garde
pas
la 60ème
semaine
de la libération,
car
certaines
églises
font ce type
de campagne,
on était là
toutes les semaines
et on a raté
la 20ème
année,
la bénédiction
est perdue.
Si
on ne s'habille
pas
d'une telle
manière,
si
nous ne sommes
pas à jour
avec
certaines
performances
religieuses,
on ne peut
pas
sentir
véritablement
cette
paix,
filiation.
Et
certains,
ils avaient
beaucoup
de zèle,
ils avaient
un zèle
honnête
et complètement
tordu
envers la
sainteté,
en voulant
garder
certaines
pratiques
religieuses.
Et
d'autres,
même
ceux qui
étaient
dans
les bons
côtés
de la
compréhension
biblique,
ils voulaient
corriger
cette
déviation
doctrinaire.
Mais
eux non plus
n'étaient pas
en train
d'agir
avec
la paix.
Et donc
cette
église
rentre
dans
une
division
à cause
des
bonnes
motivations,
on peut
dire
comme ça.
Et
donc
Galate
n'était
pas en train
de vivre
la paix
et à la
racine
de tout ça
était
un oubli,
attention,
de ce
qui nous
sommes,
de ce
qui nous
avons
déjà
en Jésus
Christ.
La solution
de
l'apôtre
Paul
n'est pas
voici
ce que
vous
devez
faire
à partir
de là,
c'est
plutôt
rappelez-vous
de qui
vous êtes
en Christ
si vous
êtes
en Christ
et marcher
en conformité
de ce
qui est
déjà
à votre
disposition.
Il n'est
pas focalisé
sur la
performance,
il n'est
pas focalisé
dans ce
que nous
pouvons
faire,
il est
plutôt
focalisé
sur ce
qui nous
sommes
en Jésus
Christ,
dans ce
que Christ
a fait
et dans
un comportement
qui devrait
être
et qui
doit
être
car il
peut
être
une
expression
naturelle
de notre
nouvelle
nature,
des influences
du Saint-Esprit
de Dieu
qui habite
en nous.
Ce n'est
pas un choix
pour un
chrétien,
de chercher
des excuses,
de coupabiliser
les circonstances
quand on n'est
pas en train
de vivre
ces caractères
symétriques
qui ont les
caractères
du Christ
qui nous a
greffés
en lui
par la
puissance
de son
esprit.
Et donc,
c'est la
quête
la plus
radicale
de la
race
humaine,
c'est une
quête
toujours
actuelle,
c'est une
paix
qu'on
cherche
à l'intérieur
et à
l'extérieur
et c'est
une paix
qui dépend
complètement
d'une
compréhension
biblique
pour
être
satisfaite.
Car pour
plus
que ce soit
facilement
dépointé
qui est
l'un des
symptômes
des péchés
les plus
évidents
dans la
société
soit
les
mentes
épais,
pour plus
que toute
la race
humaine
n'arrive
jamais
à nier
le fait
que nous
n'avons
pas la
paix,
nous avons
beau essayer
de trouver
cette paix
ou
quelque chose
qui puisse
s'approcher
de cette
conception
des
paix.
Au moins,
on a beau
essayer
supprimer
ce qui
peut
enlever
la paix
et des fois
avec une
conception
très superficielle
de paix
on pense
que c'est
tout simplement
d'être
protégé
des choses
qui peuvent
causer la
douleur.
Donc on court
après l'argent,
la protection,
la médecine
pour éviter
la douleur.
Et parfois
on est inconscient
qui ne sait pas
tout simplement
les manques
des paix
par rapport
à la peur
physique.
C'est les manques
des paix
à cause
de troubles
intérieurs.
Insatisfaction,
anxiété,
coupabilité.
Et on embrasse
des philosophies
qui veulent plutôt
supprimer ces choses
chez nous.
Non,
on est les fruits
d'une explosion
donc ça ne fait
pas de sens
de penser
à la moralité.
je dois plutôt
suivre mes désirs.
Ça doit être
la quête
la plus résitime.
Peu importe
si mes choix
ont été
immoraux
ou non,
je vais dire
que ces choses
ne font pas de sens.
Et on essaye
à chaque fois
soit de nous
victimiser
par rapport
à nos erreurs,
soit
à supprimer
la notion
d'une conscience
qui nous accuse
la notion
d'une conscience
qui nous accuse.
Et de manière privée,
parfois,
on fait recours
la génération
qui est la plus grande
consommatrice
des psychotropes
en France,
au monde.
ce qu'on a considéré
dans les œuvres
de la chair
comme la
pharmacaïa.
On embrasse
très vite
n'importe quel type
de diagnostic
aujourd'hui
pour prendre
les raccourcis
les plus intéressants
pour éviter
d'être confronté
de manière
raisonnable
avec la source
de notre manque
de paix.
Et malheureusement,
pas mal de chrétiens
qui sont en train
d'embrasser
ces méthodologies.
Qu'elles viennent
des médicaments,
qu'elles viennent
du divan,
une tendance
générale
à supprimer
la culpabilité.
À la racine,
bien sûr,
du problème
de la paix au moins,
selon les diagnostics
bibliques,
nous retrouvons
notre rébellion
contre Dieu,
péché.
Et sans
qu'on soit
responsabilisé,
répentif,
on ne va
jamais
comprendre
l'Évangile
d'une manière
qu'il puisse
nous affranchir
véritablement
de cette coupabilité.
La coupabilité
ne va jamais
disparaître
pour plus
qu'on essaie
de supprimer.
Mais il y a
une solution
et une seule solution.
C'est
de satisfaire
les mêmes exigences
qu'on sait
dans notre conscience
qu'on n'arrive
pas à satisfaire,
sauf qu'elles sont
encore
très corrompues,
cauterisées,
faibles.
On sait
qu'on n'arrive
pas à vivre
à la hauteur
de nos attentes
envers les autres
envers nous-mêmes.
mais même
ces attentes
pour plus
qu'elles vont
dans la direction
des commandements
des dieux,
elles ne sont pas
la compréhension
pure des commandements
des dieux,
qui sont
beaucoup plus profonds,
beaucoup plus élevés,
beaucoup plus exigeants.
Et Dieu ne va
jamais révâcher
ces choses.
Il ne va
jamais
suggérer
qu'on devrait
avoir un abordage
moins ferme
envers sa loi.
au contraire.
Il va démontrer
chaque fois plus
que ces petits indices
dans notre condition
pécheresse
de ce qu'on devrait
être
sont encore
très faibles
par rapport
à ce qu'on devrait
véritablement être.
Image des dieux.
Sans comme Dieu est sans.
Car il nous a créés
pour être son image.
Et c'est notamment
en étant confrontés
progressivement
par les attentes
justes et belles
des dieux envers nous
que nous arrivons
de plus en plus
à la conviction
de notre rébellion,
de notre péché
et on comprend
finalement
la racine
de ces manques
de paix.
Car c'est dans la racine
de ces manques
de paix
que Christ
vient travailler.
C'est pour régler
cette condamnation,
cette coupabilité.
nous sommes complètement
dans la dépendance
du diagnostic
biblique
pour la condition
de l'homme,
pour ces manques
de paix.
Les efforts
du monde
n'ont jamais
été capables
de satisfaire
les manques
de paix
dans le cœur
de l'homme,
dans la société
humaine.
Plus
des connaissances
n'ont pas
fait du travail,
plus des civilités
n'ont pas
fait du travail.
c'était
l'une des causes
reconnues
quand on fait
l'étude
du panorama
des philosophies,
c'est que
l'une des causes
pour les propositions
de la philosophie
ou des philosophies
existentialistes
ou de l'absurde
du relativisme,
c'était
la déception
après la révolution
industrielle
où on avait
l'espoir
qu'avec plus
des civilités,
plus des connaissances,
plus des conforts,
plus des machines,
on arriverait
finalement à la paix
et ces choses
ont abouti
aux deux grandes
guerres.
Et donc,
la Bible,
elle nous montre
partout
qu'elle est
la seule
capable
de porter
un diagnostic
qui puisse
véritablement
expliquer
pourquoi
nous avons
cette sensation
d'esclavage.
Nous sommes
esclaves
du manque
de paix.
Cet esclavage
est décrit
par la Bible
comme un esclavage
insurmontable
et un esclavage
insupportable.
c'est un esclavage
de notre condition
pécheresse,
c'est un esclavage
de la loi
de Dieu,
cette loi
que même si on n'a
pas eu connaissance
par les dix commandements
ou la loi externe
de Dieu,
nous l'avons tous
de manière embryonnaire,
perpétuelle
et universelle
chez la conscience
de tout être humain.
Voilà pourquoi
les rapports
du chrétien
vers la loi
ou les rapports
de l'être humain
vers la loi
et même les rapports
des juifs
vers la loi
c'était névrotique
car ils n'ont pas placé
selon la compréhension
dans le Nouveau Testament
de la mauvaise
interprétation juive
de la loi,
ils n'ont pas placé
la loi
dans sa position
que Dieu
a intentionné
dans le sens
que la loi
avait pour but
nous convaincre
de notre totale
condamnation
et de notre
total besoin
d'un substitut
qui puisse
l'accomplir
parfaitement
la loi
voulait garder
nos yeux
vers l'attente
du Messie parfait.
Par contre,
les courants
prédominants
d'interprétation
juive
dans la période
du Nouveau Testament
étaient
et que la loi
était un moyen
de conquérir
à faveur
de Dieu.
Ma performance
religieuse,
ma justice
propre,
ma capacité
de m'éporter
de manière sainte
et donc
l'apôtre
Paul va insister
en Galacte
partout
que ceux
qui veulent
mêler
une relation
avec Dieu
sur la base
de la loi
ne seront jamais
plaire Dieu.
Ils seront
tous condamnés.
Et voilà pourquoi
la liberté
chrétienne
est décrite
comme la liberté
de la loi
quelque part.
Donc,
ce n'est pas
une liberté
absolue
dans le sens
où
l'intention
principale
de Dieu
par la loi
c'était
de nous rappeler
qu'on a été créé
pour être son image,
c'était de nous montrer
que la loi
n'est qu'une expression
de la sainteté
et de la justice
de Dieu lui-même
et que la loi
elle est belle.
Nous devrions
aspirer
être
des êtres
humains parfaits
comme la loi
exige.
Et lorsque
la Bible
nous présente
la manière
dont Dieu
nous a sauvés
en Christ
en ayant
accompli la loi
les Christes,
la Bible
insiste
que non seulement
nous sommes
complètement
à dessous
des condamnations
de la loi
mais nous recevons
par les Saint-Esprits
la capacité
de mener
une vie
progressivement
en conformité
avec la loi.
Ce qui met
les chrétiens
dans une position
de paix
inébranable
car Christ
a tout
accompli
mais qui
pendant cette période
d'attente
du retour
de Christ
pour qu'il
rende notre
condition
glorifiée,
nous sommes
encore dans
une période
d'expérience
progressive
d'obéissance
à la loi
et c'est légitime
que notre
sensation
d'épais
envers Dieu
oscille
vis-à-vis
à notre niveau
des diligences
et des progressions
dans l'obéissance
de la parole
de Dieu.
Nous sommes
attristés
car nous savons
que nous sommes
en train
d'attrister
le Saint-Esprit
car nous ne sommes
pas en train
de faire
usage
de toutes
les puissances
qu'il met
à notre disposition
et toutes les puissances
que nous avons
dans notre nouvelle nature
pour vivre
une vie
progressivement
sainte.
Mais tous
les vrais
croyants
savent
que cette
oscillation
des paix
que nous
expérimentons
en Christ
dans l'esprit
ne peut
jamais être
élevée
à une
terreur
qui caractérisait
les rapports
dont je lui fais
envers la loi,
en je lui fais
en converti.
car le Saint-Esprit
qui nous a été donné
n'est pas un esprit
d'esclavage
devant les terreurs
de la loi,
le Saint-Esprit
est l'esprit
de filiation.
C'est une paix
radicalement différente.
C'est la paix
de savoir
que nous sommes
enfants des dieux
d'une fois
pour toutes
car si nous doutons
de cette position,
nous doutons
de l'œuvre
du Christ.
nous doutons
de l'amour
de Dieu.
Et donc
pour plus
que dans notre
expérience
des progressions
en santé,
on soit
à chaque fois
défié
par cet apprissement
quand on rate
les opportunités
des progressions
en santé,
de manifester
les fruits
de l'esprit,
de l'autre côté,
ça devrait être
inébranlable
car c'est les diables
que lorsqu'ils
viennent nous accuser
cherchent
à nous conduire
à douter
de notre filiation,
de notre salut.
C'est sa voix
accusatrice
qui est toujours
condamnatoire.
sauf que
quand les saints
esprits
nous attristent,
c'est toujours
avec une
d'espoir
cette répentance
et un don
du saint esprit
afin qu'on progresse
davantage
en santé.
Et donc par là
nous sommes
complètement sécurisés
de la conception
publique des paix.
Mon objectif
jusqu'ici
c'est
de faire
une espèce
de résumé
de la relation
entre cette
conception des paix
et les thèmes
principaux
que l'apôtre Paul
aborde
en Galate.
Car c'était
véritablement
ces crises
que les judaïsants
mal intentionnés
voulaient exploiter
dans cette communauté
légitimement chrétienne.
Voilà pourquoi
cette lettre
a été utilisée
dans une période
dans l'histoire
la plus corrompue
de l'Église.
Le XVIe siècle
lorsque l'Église
catholique romaine
a fait un mouvement
très similaire
à celui
des judaïsants.
Car les judaïsants
envers les Galates
rappelons bien
une nation
complètement païenne
qui n'avait pas
l'habitude
de l'inacollissance
des coutumes
juifs.
Mais l'apôtre
Paul est arrivé
et il a prêché
Christ.
Il a placardé
Jésus-Christ
crucifié.
Il n'a pas pris
du temps
pour expliquer
les cérémonies
sacrificielles.
Il n'y a aucun
indice
qui s'assoit
son emphase.
Et cette communauté
a compris
tout comme
vous rappelez bien
ses gardiens
devant la croix
qui est les premiers
des romans
des centennies
qui est les premiers
à déclarer
de manière
confessionnelle
véritablement
cet homme
était fils
des dieux.
Il s'est converti
indépendamment
de la connaissance
de l'Ancien Testament.
Il s'est converti
par les contacts
directs
avec celui
qui est
la lumière
infiniment
plus élevée
que toutes les ombres
de l'Ancien Testament.
Il vient bien sûr
pour confirmer
elles toutes
et la connaissance
de l'Ancien Testament
enrichit
notre compréhension
du Christ aussi.
Mais la réalité
c'est qu'une expérience
de conversion
réelle et légitime
avec Jésus seul
est capable
de nous conduire
à la conformité
envers la loi
des dieux.
Et c'était
la situation
des Galactes.
Ils ont reçu
le Saint-Esprit
comme confirmation
de leur conversion
et ils n'étaient pas
en train
de se soumettre
à la circoncision
observer les dates
ou dépendre
de leur performance
pour croire
qu'ils seraient bénis
ou que leur assurance
de salut
puisse dépendre
de leur comportement.
et ils progressaient
très bien
dans la foi.
Les judaïsants
arrivent
et disent
ok,
Christ
il est
l'accomplissement
sauf que
la seule manière
éthique
de progresser
en santé
après votre salut
c'est d'observer
les traditions
de cette institution
juive.
Vous devez
vous circoncire,
vous devez observer
certaines dates,
vous devez vous porter
comme nous.
sinon
vous ne pouvez pas
expérimenter
réellement
la sensation
d'être enfants
de Dieu.
Ils étaient déjà
enfants de Dieu
et de manière
très pernicieuse
ils ont permis
que cela
contamine
la communauté
et ils ont développé
cette relation
névrotique.
Douter
de la fidélisation
légitime,
possibilité
de perdre
de salut
que Paul va
confronter
comme une idée
de diminuer
l'œuvre du Christ
si les saluts
se donnent
par la loi
Christ est mort
en vent
c'est ce que
dit le rappeur
très pauvre.
Si cela dépend
de votre performance
pour être béni
par Dieu
Dieu n'aurait pas
envoyé son Fils.
C'est de suggérer
c'est clair
que Dieu
n'allait pas
envoyer son
propre Fils.
Et c'était
le névrotisme
qui s'est emparé
de cette communauté.
Qu'à un moment
dans leur passé
avait déjà goûté
de manière légitime
cette paix absolue
mais qui s'est permis
de douter
de plus en plus
de leur salut
sur la base
de leur performance.
C'est la même chose
que l'Église catholique
a fait
au XVIe siècle
en disant
ok Christ
c'est par la foi
en lui
qu'on est sauvé
mais pas que.
Il faut faire
les œuvres
de pénitence
il faut payer
les indulgences
il faut déléguer
l'assurance
de votre salut
au prêtre
et nous avons vu
la génération
la plus névrotique
dans la relation
avec Dieu.
Dieu
il était comme
s'il était
la figure
de la loi
un doigt
pointé contre nous.
C'était la notion
d'un Dieu
contre nous
à chaque instant
en cherchant
à identifier
un péché commis
pour enlever
le salut.
Luther
il était névrotique
avant sa conversion.
Il disait
qu'il était tellement honnête
envers ses pensées
que quand il allait
au confessionnaire
il confessait
ses fautes
mais quand il était
en train de rentrer
dans sa chambre
au milieu même
du parcours
il revenait au confessionnaire
à cause des pensées
qui venaient à son esprit.
C'est la foi
yo-yo
et salut yo-yo
perdu, retrouvé
mais ce qu'on ne perçoit pas
c'est que ça
non seulement
enlève
la paix du cœur
du chrétien
mais ça
va pendre
en image
de Dieu
complètement
à l'opposé
de ce que Dieu
révèle lui-même
dans sa parole
un Dieu
pour nous
résolu
et déterminé
à nous dire
n'ayez pas peur
et qui prouve
que nous ne pouvons pas
mêler une relation
avec Dieu
toujours dans cette base
des méfiances
de douter
de son amour
de ses bonnes intentions
car il a prouvé
son amour
pour nous
Romain 5
en ceci
lorsqu'on était encore
ennemi de Dieu
il a envoyé
son propre fils
pour nous
c'est quand on était
dans la pleine rébellion
contre Dieu
il envoie son fils
pour nous
c'est un Dieu
évidemment
dans la plus grande
et explicite
manifestation
d'une mission
des paix
Dieu était un Christ
réconciliant les mondes
avec lui-même
et donc la vérité centrale
pour nous
c'est que
la paix
est un élément
essentiel
de la liberté chrétienne
et elle doit être
constamment
expérimentée
elle doit être
évidemment visible
et elle doit être
préservée
et cultivée
dans la vie
des tout
véritables
enfants des dieux
parce que
Paul présente
les œuvres
de la chair
on voit de manière
très claire
que la plupart
des éléments
sont des indices
des manques
de paix
donc on peut revenir
un peu
pour lire les textes
ensemble
verset 19
or les œuvres
de la chair
sont manifestes
ce sont
l'impudicité
l'impureté
la dissolution
l'idolâtrie
la magie
les inimitiés
les querelles
les jalousies
les animosités
les disputes
les divisions
les sectes
l'envie
l'ivronnierie
les excès de table
et les choses
semblables
et pour plus
que certains
de ces éléments
ne semblent pas
être liés
au manque de paix
ils sont tous liés
comme on verra
mais la majorité
est explicitement
liée
à l'opposé
de la paix
la guerre
les crises
les troubles
ce qu'il dit
c'est
je vous ai dit
d'avance
et c'est vanté encore
comme je l'ai déjà dit
que ceux qui commettent
de telles choses
n'hériteront point
les rangs des dieux
intéressants
il n'est pas en train
de dire
ceux qui commettent
de telles choses
perdront leur salut
ou ceux qui
ne commettent pas
ces choses
conquériront
les saluts
il est en train
de décrire
que cette liste
est une liste
d'évaluation
pour faire un constat
c'est pas une liste
de faire
ou ne pas faire
c'est une liste
qui est en train
de décrire
ce que nous étions
tous avant
la conversion
gouverné par
nos passions
et c'est
que nous ne sommes
plus
car la conception
d'héritage
elle est très
intentionnelle
car c'est
une conception
de quelque chose
qui nous est
communiquée
par les pères
c'est une évidence
des filiations
quand on a considéré
non seulement
cette conception
d'héritage
mais c'est
qu'il va confronter
avec les œuvres
de la chair
pour la suite
mais les fruits
de l'esprit
donc à nouveau
il n'est pas
en train de dire
mais
ceux qui
s'efforcent
pour produire
ces choses
conquériront
les statuts
d'enfants des dieux
vous êtes avec moi
les fruits
de l'esprit
c'est à dire
c'est un constat
quand on pose la question
qui sont les enfants
des dieux
qui sont les vrais
enfants des dieux
ce sont ceux
qui ne vivent
plus
dans la pratique
constante
ou dans l'esclavage
constant
des œuvres
de la chair
les impulsions
de péché
mais ils sont ceux
qui ont été
l'objet
d'une transformation
de la part des dieux
qu'ils ont été
faits
enfants des dieux
par une nouvelle nature
opérée
par l'esprit
des dieux
et par les faits
qui sont devenus
l'habitation
de l'esprit
des dieux
une habitation permanente
et si le saint esprit
habite en nous
il produit
inévitablement
en nous
ces fruits
vous comprenez
c'est pas faire
c'est nature
c'est manifestation
c'est produire
vous comprenez
la différence
elle est très importante
et donc
ces fruits
de l'esprit
ce que Paul
vise à faire
à nouveau
c'est de rappeler
qui vous êtes
en Christ
si vous êtes
né
du saint esprit
c'est le terme
qu'il va utiliser
dans tous ces passages
donc
la confrontation
d'essayer
qui caractérisait
notre vie
avant la conversion
et ce qui doit
caractériser
notre vie
aujourd'hui
c'est pour nous rappeler
attention
au moins
qu'à partir
du moment
où on a été
véritablement converti
on a expérimenté
de manière radicale
les fruits
de saint esprit
on a connu
cette nature
spirituelle
de cette amour
de cette joie
de cette paix
patience
montée
etc
on a expérimenté
de manière profonde
et légitime
et radicale
une sorte d'amour
de joie
de paix
de patience
qu'on n'avait
jamais goûté
avant
on a compris
qui
c'était grâce
à notre union
avec jésus christ
par la foi
et par l'esprit
car le saint esprit
c'est comme la sève
qui coule du christ
envers nous
la bible dit
que la foi en christ
c'est comme si on était
greffé en lui
qui est la vigne
donc c'est sa vie
ou son caractère
manifesté
envers nous
et en nous
et donc
tous ces éléments
sont des évidences
de ceux qui sont nés
de nouveau
et qui sont nés
à Christ
donc voilà pourquoi
la vérité centrale
pour nous
à chaque fois
revient
que chaque élément
complémentaire
du fruit de l'esprit
qui est singulier
est un élément
qui doit être
présent
expérimenté
et évidemment
visible
dans la vie
de tout véritable chrétien
ce qui veut dire
que si jamais
comme les Galates
on a été susceptible
à des déviations
si on a relâché
dans notre bataille
contre les restes
de la chair
si on a laissé
l'influence
des propositions
du monde
pour nous apporter
une autre sorte
de paix
et de joie
nous avons cédé
au reste
attention
la chair
dans les passages
est décrite
comme quelque chose
qui a été crucifié
elle a souffert
un coup mortel
mais elle n'est pas
encore complètement morte
sauf que
l'arsenal des dieux
est du côté du croyant
une nouvelle nature
la présence
de la troisième
personne de la trinité
dieu lui-même
en nous
l'influence prédominante
chez les chrétiens
c'est le saint-esprit
et donc
notre volonté prédominante
est de progresser
en sainteté
c'est de préserver
ses fruits
et de manifester
c'est de vivre
une vie
constante
de la manifestation
du Christ
en nous
et à travers nous
nous sommes devant
ce qui devrait être
la constante
de toutes nos vies
comment
nous expérimentons
à l'intérieur
et comment nous manifestons
à l'extérieur
ces éléments
amour
joie
paix
est-ce que vous êtes
connu comme un vrai
chrétien
dans le sens où
est-ce que vous êtes
connu comme une personne
remplie et débordante
l'amour
des joies
remplie et débordante
des paix
si ce n'est pas le cas
c'est un reproche
qui doit être efficace
dans vos vies
car Dieu fait usage
des reproches
de l'apôtre Paul
pour redresser
les galates
on n'a pas une deuxième
lettre aux galates
ils ont été redressés
et c'est la même chose
pour nous tous
si un jour
vous avez goûté
quelque chose
radical
de ces éléments
vous êtes capable
encore aujourd'hui
par la puissance
du Saint-Esprit
de continuer
à reproduire
ces choses
et expérimenter
donc la question
pour nous
à chaque fois
c'est comment
préserver
cultiver
expérimenter
et manifester
car Paul va décrire
aussi cette bataille
c'est comme un jardin
à nouveau
radicalement
on doit tous
avoir connu
pour nous considérer
chrétiens
si c'était vrai
pour nous
c'est encore possible
de continuer
de les faire
et nous les ferons
comme un jardin
où nous avons
déjà à notre disposition
tous les outils
nécessaires
pour freiner
les manifestations
des mauvaises herbes
et pour faire avancer
un beau jardin
et pour réjouir
de ce que ces jardins
peuvent produire
et on a considéré
devant chaque complément
du fruit de l'esprit
cette réalité
donc comment préserver
cultiver
expérimenter
et manifester
la paix chrétienne
dans notre vie quotidienne
la question
qu'on va poser
aujourd'hui
c'est qui
ou les points
qu'on va aborder
c'est pour vivre
dans la paix
de l'esprit
nous devons
et j'aurai
trois réponses
une première
aujourd'hui
car nous avons
jusqu'ici
essayé de faire
la connexion
avec un rappel
de la lettre
car ça faisait longtemps
qu'on ne revenait pas
à Galate
et nous allons considérer
les autres
dans les dimanches prochains
donc voici
pour vivre
la paix de l'esprit
nous devons
numéro un
comprendre
et expérimenter
la nature organique
de la paix chrétienne
deuxième point
qu'on verra plus tard
cultiver et préserver
la connexion directe
à la racine
de cette paix
qui est Christ
et troisième point
nous devons
nous efforcer
intentionnellement
pour manifester
et pour constater
l'efficacité
de cette paix
contre les oeuvres
de la chair
et pour maximiser
la manifestation
du fruit de l'esprit
donc
relation
pourquoi l'apôtre Paul
est en train de présenter
les fruits de l'esprit
en contraste
avec les oeuvres
de la chair
et de quelle manière
la paix
se rapporte
aux autres éléments
du fruit de l'esprit
qui toujours se manifestent
à la une
car nous devons
être intentionnels
si nous avons déjà
la puissance
à notre disposition
nous devons être
intentionnels
pour produire
les fruits
ok
et donc
la première considération
c'est que nous devons
comprendre
et nous devons
expérimenter
la nature organique
de la paix chrétienne
déjà
malheureusement
quand on parle
des paix
aujourd'hui
ou quand on pense même
à ce qui doit représenter
les chrétiens
dans la société
on a une image
très tordue
de ce qui est
les chrétiens
de ce qui était
l'oeuvre du Christ
et c'est qu'il y a
tout simplement
la paix
nous vivons
dans la génération
du dieu
de la tolérance
qui n'est pas
la tolérance
selon la compréhension
de la patience
biblique
nous devons
toujours chercher
à aimer
les personnes
qui sont devant nous
quand on va faire
l'évangélisation
par exemple
nous devons
être prêts
à accueillir
toutes les personnes
peu importe
quelle soit
sa position politique
ou quelle soit
sa réputation
sociale
quel soit
son niveau
d'éducation
son origine
peu importe
quelle soit
même
la perception
qu'elle a
d'elle-même
ou peu importe
qu'elle soit
la volonté
qu'elle puisse
avoir
pour elle-même
dans l'idée
qu'elle
saurait
elle-même
qu'elle serait
son bien
malheureusement
plusieurs chrétiens
dans nos jours
doivent être
réprochés
car ils font
la confusion
entre parler
avec conviction
et parler
avec agressivité
et qui veulent
exprimer
leur conviction
sans la sensibilité
et nous sommes
devant des personnes
qui sont
avoglées par Satan
esclaves
de leur péché
et qui font
une scission
en desservice
à l'évangélisation
quand on veut
faire des menaces
que certains groupes
ou certaines pratiques
vont à l'enfer
nous devons toujours
nous inclure
et nous devons dire
avec fermeté
il y a l'espoir
pour tous
mais une fois
que vous avez
rencontré
véritablement Christ
vos vies
seront transformées
on insiste
pour défendre
les principes
de la famille
et la complémentarité
biblique
même devant
ceux qui ont
cherché
de manière
très pécheresse
soit à vivre
la vie
de l'immoralité
sexuelle
dans la débauche
soit
dans la pratique
de l'homosexualité
soit dans l'inversion
des rôles
familiales
car tout cela
est péché
et tous les péchés
méritent l'enfer
mais si nous insistons
sur certaines convictions
c'est car nous savons
que c'est le mieux
pour la personne
même
qui est devant nous
et c'est par amour
qu'on insiste
dans les convictions
bibliques
car nous savons
que les paramètres
des dieux
sont toujours
les mieux
pour l'épanouissement
de chaque individu
de chaque être humain
tous sont les bienvenus
mais une fois
que tous
seront confrontés
comme un jour
on a été confrontés
dans nos péchés
particuliers
tous doivent reconnaître
qu'ils sont
condamnés à l'enfer
et qu'un Christ
est seul
il retrouve
la réconciliation
et la paix
c'est pour dire
que la tolérance
selon les mondes
qui veut tout accepter
est une tolérance
égoïste
une mère
ou un père
qui ne veut pas
corriger son enfant
parfois
c'est un signe
qu'il aime
plutôt son image
même devant son enfant
qu'il est bien
de son enfant
et c'est la même chose
pour nous
dans toutes les circonstances
de nos vies
sous les peurs
d'être
rejeté
refusé
on s'éprime
de dire
les blessures
qui guérissent
comme l'Avi nous dit
ces blessures
de la mi-réelle
qui veut véritablement
notre bien
donc la tolérance
selon la Bible
c'est
plutôt de la patience
mais une patience
toujours
connectée
au vrai amour
une patience
toujours connectée
à la vérité
une patience
qui
sait attendre
les moments
opportuns
pour conduire
à la réparation
à la restauration
mais c'est
une patience
proactive
à conduire
la personne
à la restauration
au diagnostic
réel
de son problème
et à la solution
réelle
de son problème
et donc malheureusement
aujourd'hui
on a cette idée
que la paix
ou les pacifismes
ou les chrétiens
doivent être vus
comme quelqu'un
qui n'a pas
les saveurs
et celle
qui a perdu
sa saveur
car il n'a aucun contraste
avec le monde
la lumière
qui a été cachée
car il n'a aucun contraste
avec les ténèbres
de ses mondes
il y a aussi
cette notion
des pacifismes
le pacifisme
c'est pas
de chercher
la vraie paix
et certains
d'entre nous
peuvent se vanter
de se considérer
des personnes
très calmes
très paisibles
et parfois
ça manque
des fibres
car si à la fin
des comptes
les problèmes
fondamentaux
de l'humanité
c'est la rébellion
contre Dieu
là où il n'y a pas
de réconciliation
réelle
dans les relations
il n'y a pas
de vraie paix
par exemple
les traités
parfois
des guerres
ne signifient pas
la réconciliation
entre deux pays
la décision
et même
l'habilité
qu'on a développé
dans nos sociétés
aujourd'hui
où on se sent
toujours persécuté
menacé
où on se sent
qu'on n'a pas
les droits même
d'exprimer publiquement
nos convictions
c'est abominable
à Dieu
cette capacité
d'éviter
les troubles
les problèmes
car les jours
où vous travaillerez
pour produire
la vraie réconciliation
entre deux personnes
et ça faisait longtemps
qu'elles se disputaient
vous allez voir
comment ça veut
la peine
de prendre les risques
de s'exposer
de souffrir même
pour produire
une vraie réconciliation
et la réconciliation
la plus élevée
c'était grâce
c'était une réconciliation
très coûteuse
un Christ
qui a voulu
réconcilier Dieu
avec nous
et qui s'est mis
au milieu
de feux croisés
un Dieu
qui a dû déverser
sa juste colère
contre nous
pour la faire converger
en soi-même
dans la personne
de son fils
et un Christ
qui pendant
qu'il proclamait
la vérité
pour nous réconcilier
a été
injustement
exterminé
et donc
le pacifisme
tel qu'on voit
dans la politique
ou dans notre relation
ne signifie pas
d'être
véritablement
des pacificateurs
cette paix
elle est tellement
importante
et tellement fondamentale
que le Seigneur
Jésus Christ
lui-même
associe
la reconnaissance
des vrais chrétiens
avec
la vraie
pacification
les vrais
procureurs
de la paix
heureux sont
ceux qui procurent
la paix
car ils seront
appelés
fils des dieux
donc
c'est pas
le pacifisme
ce n'est pas
la tolérance
dans la conception
grecque
c'est intéressant
c'était une notion
vague
de sérénité
de tranquillité
et une notion
d'avoir
une pensée
quiète
plutôt calme
peut-être une personne
serait
identifiée
comme une personne
pacifique
si elle était
plutôt austère
parfois
dans certains courants
c'est là
représenté surtout
d'éviter
à tout prix
les mauvaises
circonstances
mais c'est une conception
qui restait
assez individuelle
c'était quelque chose
pour les profits
personnels
c'était une quête
pour l'absence
de douleurs
dans les corps
et des troubles
dans la pensée
et voilà pourquoi
en général
les philosophies
vont dans cette direction
de manière
comme j'ai déjà mentionné
pas légitime
mais des essais
pour supprimer
la coupabilité
dans la pensée
rationaliser
les péchés
je me rappelle
qu'avant ma conversion
j'ai pratiqué
certains péchés
toujours
en essayant
d'alléger
leur poids
dans ma pensée
à cause
d'un trauma
d'enfance
mon oncle
a perdu
les mouvements
de bras
dans un accident
de voiture
à cause de l'alcool
donc j'ai jamais
bu de l'alcool
pendant ma jeunesse
à cause de ça
et quand on allait
dans les fêtes
des fois
je me permettais
de sauter les murs
pour ne pas payer
la consommation basique
et je me disais
dans ma tête
je bois
je bois pas
donc c'est pas grave
dans mes relations
promiscues
je me disais
la même chose
je suis pas en train
de faire du mal
à personne
mais au fond
même de mon coeur
de ma conscience
je savais
que ça ne suffisait pas
donc toutes ces
philosophies
athéisme
relativisme
c'est cette manière
de chercher
à apaiser
la conscience
et comme dit
les prophètes
c'est comme
une couverte
une couverture
courte
on essaie
de couvrir
la poitrine
les pieds
sont froids
on essaie
de couvrir
les pieds
c'est jamais
suffisant
la vraie paix
n'est pas
la conception grecque
elle est plus proche
de la conception juive
on aime bien parler
des chalons
et c'est une conception
très élevée
de paix
dans la conception juive
la vraie paix
est une question
des perfections
des relations
en toutes les interactions
des lettres
humains
avec cet univers
la paix
avec l'environnement
mais surtout
dans les relations
personnelles
je ne pourrais pas
être en paix
je serais toujours
troublé
dans ma paix
d'abord
dans ma relation
personnelle
avec
moi-même
car dans la conception juive
la notion
des significations
a été toujours
radicale
but d'existence
créée
à l'image
des dieux
et quand on considère
les fruits de l'esprit
on va mieux comprendre
mais c'est
la paix
selon les juifs
c'est cette notion
de fleurir
s'épanouir
remplir
les attentes
de la conscience
pour être
ce que je devrais être
c'est la conscience
qu'on a été créée
pour être
l'image des dieux
et nous ne trouvons pas
la paix
si nous ne sommes pas
intègres
complets
les manques
de symétrie
entre les éléments
du fruit de l'esprit
je sais si c'est là
mais je n'ai pas
la tempérance
j'ai l'amour
la joie
mais je n'ai pas
la droiture
ça me manque
la douceur
c'était la sensation
pour les juifs
qu'il n'était pas
complet
il n'était pas
un vrai représentant
de ces dieux
indivisibles
qui est parfait
dans tous ses attributs
et particulièrement
relationnels
personnels
et bien sûr
que ça devrait
s'étendre
dans ces relations
interpersonnelles
avec les autres
donc la paix
pour les juifs
n'était pas si tant
même si elles
incluaient
la restauration
de la société
parfaite
en aidant
être dans un jardin
parfait
avec prospérité
ces chalons
cette conception
des chalons
était essentiellement
une salutation
relationnelle
!
et surtout
dans sa relation
avec Dieu
voilà pourquoi
pour plus que
chalons
étaient évoqués
comme les sommets
de l'objectif
de la vie humaine
dans la conscience
des juifs
il savait
qu'il n'avait
jamais expérimenté
effectivement
ces chalons
et quand on considère
l'extension
de cette considération
de chalons
envers
la conception
du sabbat
c'est un jour
sur sept
des rituels
religieux
qui faisaient
les peuples
transpirer
c'était les jours
les plus fatigants
de la semaine
c'était les jours
qu'on appelait
les jours de repos
c'était les jours
de l'auto-examen
où je devrais
amener
les sacrifices
c'était les jours
des travails
infatigables
dans les temples
ou dans les tabernacles
qui portaient
un poids
très mélancolique
c'était la notion
du sabbat parfait
perdu
dans la création
et l'attente
du sabbat parfait
qui viendrait
et donc c'était
un sabbat
qui n'était
jamais complet
voilà pourquoi
nous ne pouvons
que comprendre
ce que signifie
la vraie paix
quand on arrive
en Christ
le Seigneur Jésus
Christ
qui est appelé
notre sabbat
les princes
de la paix
en Christ
nous avons
la paix
avec Dieu
l'évangile
de la paix
et voilà pourquoi
l'autor d'hébreu
va dire
de manière
tellement explicite
qui lui
il est notre
sabbat
notre repos
les dimanches
pour nous
la célébration
du fait
qu'il est
Seigneur Jésus
Christ
a accompli
parfaitement
les sabbats
et c'est très important
pour nous
on va revenir
sur la notion
du Christ
et c'est intéressant
dans ces trois jours
dont la vie
nous parle
à propos
de la mort
du Christ
il est mort
les vendredis
soir
il ressuscite
les dimanches
matin
il y a un seul jour
qu'il va
pleinement
se reposer
les sabbats
il était
l'accomplissement
parfait
son oeuvre
était accomplie
à la croix
de ceux
qui l'a payé
et les repos
originales
de la création
représentaient
les jours
du repos
de celui
qui avait
accompli
parfaitement
son oeuvre
il a accompli
parfaitement
son oeuvre
quand il était
crucifié
père
j'ai livré
mon esprit
dans tes mains
tout est accompli
je suis venu
sur terre
pour vivre
la vie parfaite
qu'aucun autre
n'arrive à vivre
j'ai vécu
cette vie
sous la loi
pour accomplir
parfaitement
la loi
des dieux
pour pouvoir
communiquer
ma justice
à tous ceux
qui vont croire
en moi
et lorsque j'ai dû
payer les prix
pour leur transgression
et leur péché
je suis allé
à la croix
et j'ai tout souffert
Dieu a pris
les cris
des dettes
contre nous
il l'a effacé
en les clouant
à la croix
ces documents
qui étaient
contenus
complètement
détruits
car parfaitement
satisfaits
par Christ
et notre paix
scellés
avec les sangs
du Christ
donc
en ayant
accompli
parfaitement
son œuvre
Christ a pu
reposer
les sabbats
parfaits
et il a
inauguré
la nouvelle création
avec sa résurrection
voilà pourquoi
on célèbre
les dimanches
avec une conception
infiniment plus élevée
et une expérience
beaucoup plus profonde
de paix
les dimanches pour nous
c'est un jour
des repos
et célébrations
avec l'expérimentation
d'une paix
qui les juifs
qui n'ont pas pu goûter
dans la même intensité
dans la même compréhension
car ils étaient encore
dans l'ombre
et dans l'attente
du vrai sabbat
donc la paix
dont la Bible nous parle
c'est cette paix
qui a été
réalisée par Christ
et qui peut être
réjouie en Christ
car par cette union
avec Christ
nous avons l'expérience
d'avoir payé
toute notre dette
et d'être parfaitement
sécurisé
pour toujours
car il a fait
une oeuvre parfaite
nous sommes
les enfants de Dieu
et voilà pourquoi
les Saintes Esprits
de Dieu
viennent habiter en nous
avec un des rôles
principaux
qui est
communiquer
à notre esprit
que nous sommes
les enfants de Dieu
Dieu ne nous a pas
donné un esprit
d'esclavage
pour souffrir
les menaces
de la gloire
Dieu nous a donné
un esprit
de filiation
et c'est à partir
de là
qu'on commence
à comprendre
de quelle manière
organique
étant connecté
à Christ
par l'esprit
cette paix
est une caractéristique
radicale
et expérimentale
des tout vrais chrétiens
ce qui nous prépare
pour vivre
une vie de paix
et manifester
cette paix
dans la société
des choses
qu'on va aborder plus
la semaine prochaine